and long range they've  increased their three-point attempts  this season  from 31 last year to about 37-38 per  game this year and  see george and cameron payne having some  words and  now booker getting involved  i don't know what paul george is really  upset about here  [Applause]  i really don't i mean he's hot as a  firecracker i mean so  i mean he's hot as a firecracker i don't  know what he expects i mean  he he's lucky he didn't play in the 80s  they would have been a top couple of  braves off by now  but i mean that's a good block there  from payne and he just fell on him after  he blocked the shot  so i'm just trying to figure out why  paul george is a little upset and you  can see cameron payne  didn't say anything devin booker took  exception to  the response from paul george  we know about the competitive juices of  one devin booker you know there's always  surprises